I remember God saying the first time
Connor came to Australia in Sydney
um you know there was a bit of
Australian patriotism
that you know just being like okay you
know some of my best friends are in my
home country I kind of want to know what
they feel about Australia right so I
remember I said to them I was like how
did you guys like Sydney how did you
guys like Australia and I think gone put
it best uh in a in a rare display of
British optimism
he said uh it's like you know the only
complaint that I have is that I have
nothing to complain about
and then you were like it's like it's
like uh you said it's something along
the lines of like Australia's like
uh the UK except everyone's happy yeah
yeah yeah it's unfair this should have
been ours
hey man you're the ones that brought us
here yeah exactly it wasn't supposed to
be this way why do we have why like the
outside right now when it's raining I
was like wow this is great weather in
the UK
yeah so we were doing the trash taste
Cafe earlier today did any of you guys
go
yeah so I remember like the one number
one thing that people ask me when uh it
started raining was that oh you must be
cold right now right and I'm like no I'm
at home right now this is great
um but yeah the the first thing that I
noticed about Australia when I came here
uh I just had the instant realization of
oh this is what British people could be
like if we had good weather
I'm like you guys are like England and
the UK except you were just like taken
to the next level you guys are actually
happy yeah what was I remember at Smash
in Sydney
um it was like the first day and it was
like you know I kind of overcast like
there was some clouds in the sky but you
know still good weather you know nice
and sunny and uh and I remember God was
taught you were talking like a fan of
the con and I I overheard the fan being
like Oh yeah you know I know it's your
first time in Sydney blah blah blah but
uh yeah you know apologies for the [__]
weather
you just like looked at him like
this is [__] weather what are you
talking about I like how a podcast has
become so the weather yeah right that's
what we talk about I was uh because I
had no idea what we're going to talk
about today I was in the when we were in
that room earlier I was like Googling
like things about Australia but it's
gonna be something fun to talk about
sure um and I googled the happiest
cities in Australia what do you guys
think number one was
see that's what I thought for some
reason Yahoo news said Canberra
[Applause]
which is the biggest cap I've ever heard
in my life I feel like the like the
three people there that's not a good
enough sample size right like that's
that's unfair I now that you say that I
really want to take these boys to
Canberra just just what's there
nothing yeah nothing yeah is there
anyone from Canberra here right now
wow
the population the only resident of
Canberra right there
the only reason that City exists is
because Melbourne and Sydney couldn't
put their dicks away right like that was
like oh yeah yeah literally okay fine
fine we'll make a whole new city
it's like it's barely a city dude it's
literally like all we have is like what
do we have in camera it's like the the
Parliament House uh which is like not
interesting in the slightest uh we have
that who cares about that we have like a
we have like a giant porn Factory there
for some reason
do you guys know about this
apparently in the ACT it's the only
state in Australia where it's legal to
film porn
yeah all the guys are like why am I not
living in Canberra right now
but like so yeah I remember like the
first time I drove through Canberra uh
because we were going somewhere I forgot
where we were not Canberra thank god
um we drove past it and I was like oh
it's my first time in Canberra like this
is sick you know I've always wanted to
see what it was like because I'd only
heard about it it's like it's the
capital city of Australia I went there
and it's like
oh my God the level of depression I felt
just like driving through this city was
insane and then there was this giant
like massive like five or six story just
completely pitch black building and and
I was like Dad what's that
and he was like that's the porn house
son
the what the water house the porn house
oh the porn house okay that's the porn
house son and I'm like Dad I'm 10. I
don't know what that is so don't worry
you'll find out soon enough and uh yeah
that's my only impression of Canberra
but do you think it's uh better than
Perth because we know a few people from
Perth yes and everyone the only thing I
know about Perth is everyone tries to
get out of Perth as soon as possible I
don't know if that's true or not I mean
do you think it's true or
how many people from Perth
wow you traveled half the [__] world
to get here then
well because like okay I've personally
never been to Perth so I I can only
speculate right right but it is true
that I know about three or four people
all YouTubers by the way uh Kevin and
Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin pinken cowboy
who were born and raised in Perth who
just coincidentally none of them live in
Perth anymore
so I'm like well I mean that but then
again it's like I feel Australians have
this tendency to travel like we we love
traveling for some reason why is that
what because you're in the middle yeah
you're in the middle of nowhere so I
guess that's true yeah I guess the
closest country to us is Papua New
Guinea and like who the [__] wants to go
to Papua New Guinea unless someone in
this audience is from Papua New Guinea
okay you're good you're good you talk
[__] you can talk [__] all right yeah uh
yeah so
I don't know it's like yeah what what
are like the Australian Hot Holiday uh
holiday Parts because because you guys
have to travel at least like [__] at
least six seven hours to like the
nearest place surely right yeah where do
you guys normally go like Bali is pretty
common right yeah like so we have this
thing in Australia called schoolies
um yeah that's that's World fast and
PTSD for some of you uh so it's cool
okay so School leads is this thing where
uh at the end of graduation basically
it's like a a graduation party of sorts
um and uh you know kids put in their own
money to go travel you know go play
basically it's like is it like a gap
yeah no no no not a gap year so so it's
basically just like maybe a week at most
they go out and it's basically just like
the last hooray of like yeah we
graduated from high school everyone's
like at least 18 now so we can all
legally drink so let's just go get
[__] up in some country and for some
reason Bali is like the go-to place why
does why does everything got to be like
e in Australia everything has to end
with something like wait what do you
mean like schooly or chewy or like
there's gonna be more examples right
everything just doesn't sound real here
although no I I feel other than skooly
and chewy most things end with an o
That's who yeah you know like uh [__]
Servo uh smoko uh [__]
Pavo I haven't heard that word in a
while
it's just like it's like a Simpsons
language sometimes you guys you guys got
to come home and learning and using some
of this words because it there's a
reason why I still use it to this day
because it's just so convenient
it is it really is like you know I mean
it does roll off the tongue yeah like
one thing I never understood is that
yeah a lot of your slang words end in
O's yeah uh and then for your currency
you have Australian dollars right yeah
why do you not call it the dollar that
just that just that just seems like it
would fare well I don't know like it's
because it's actually called the dollar
we do
um
so uh yeah I mean you know we've told
that story in trash days of how I fooled
meleen into legitimately thinking the
Australian dollar was called the dollar
either can I yeah can I take a moment to
just like I I was I was buying a coffee
and they gave me the change yeah and
this [__] 50p
if I threw this up in the air a crater
would form when it came down what the
[__] is this
this must have cost like a hundred
dollars worth of metal to me what the
[__] is there a reason why it's it's
funny you say that because like until
you pointed that out I it's I was like
oh yeah that is a big [__] coin it
just like you know you know come from
the UK we have coins that look really
like extravagant like this feels so
medieval
like especially like the pounds like the
Shilling the dollar yeah it does yeah
the two dollars it feels like something
like I'm like yes here you go peasants
take it
I have one gold piece in 150 bludgeon
piece here you go povos yeah because you
were one of the first country to
introduce uh contactless payment right
yeah yeah like after seeing your 50p
coin I understand why you needed it yeah
yeah there's a reason why no one carries
coins anymore
shut up Counter-Strike
this is more important
talking about the weight of a 50 cent
coin yeah
yeah but like then again it's like I
don't know Australia I feel has this
like tendency to be the first to invent
or come up with things but not be the
best at it like what like what uh like
Wi-Fi
oh where you guys invented [__]
invented Wi-Fi did you know this yeah we
invented is this an I made it the [__]
up moment no there is no way this is
true it's it's from the University of
Adelaide of all places
how do you know this off by heart
because uh just a fun fact about
Australia I like telling people yeah so
I think it's like the University of
Adelaide or somewhere like that that
invented Wi-Fi
reason we have the shittest Wi-Fi like
what what happened
um yeah I don't know about capitalism
that's what happened yeah I mean like I
was searching up some other weird facts
about Australia and Melbourne as well
yeah and I found out I guess we also had
this on the Australia live stream that
we did before uh that Melbourne was
almost called Bat Mania yeah
did you guys know about this because of
uh the the founder John John Batman yeah
that just sounds like a meme there is no
way this is real we have only 500 places
named [__] in the UK and I think we're
like we don't want to judge I don't
think we get to say I mean Australia has
some pretty fantastically named
townsends I still got to go there man I
still got to go yeah you don't there's
like 20 people who live there it's in
like the butt [__] middle of nowhere in
Queensland uh we also have uh banana
in Queensland by what we have a town
called banana anyone from banana no
anyone anyone from banana no one no I
don't even think any of you have been to
banana
what is that
bananas why is it called okay actually I
was looking up some like other things
about Australia
um and I saw something about the big
banana or something oh yeah the national
pride the big banana now you guys are
oddly proud about do you want to explain
that I mean I don't know much about it I
know it's in Queensland somewhere I was
really disappointed when I found out the
big banana is not in fact in banana uh I
feel that was a missed opportunity but
yeah it's just this one
I don't know just I guess
huh mistake again see a tourist mistake
I don't know uh where we just have this
giant sculpture of a banana and
apparently it's like the biggest fruit
sculpture in the world it's like wow
what a flex banana is the best thing
ever
well maybe you should go to the big
banana I should yeah yeah although also
actually uh Connor you'd also hate that
in New South Wales we have a town called
Orange as well
Australia's too [__] big it is it is
it really is like I don't know like uh
there's there's some parts of Australia
that I always forget almost exist and I
know that's like a me like does
Australia really exist it's not real
let's not open that okay yeah uh but um
I don't know if this is just like a me
thing but I always forget that Darwin
exists
do you know what I mean this okay so
Australia uh has you know obviously same
as America split up its Estates all
right we're in Victoria right now
um and one of the states is called the
Northern Territory have a guess as to
why it's called that I don't know
because it's in the north
um and and the capital of the Northern
Territory is this town called Darwin
yeah I know but shout out to the sheep
in the audience yeah no like because the
Northern Territory has like massive
amounts of sheep
um but I mean I've never been there
before but like is that why he barged
yeah I was like I just thought he was
like yeah yeah it wasn't just like a
weirdo making a sheep but
um yeah so like the capital of obviously
the capital of Victoria is Melbourne
um and you know each state has the
capitals and the capital of the Northern
Territory is Darwin but the problem is
for one
who's who's been to Darwin before
okay well that's quite a lot about a lot
of people yeah yeah what the [__] is
there to do in Darwin nothing yeah
that's what I thought why did you guys
go then
oh I noticed that all you guys say is
nothing is there anything to do in
Melbourne
okay
maybe there's half nothing